[Musik]
was ist ihr das haus monat in der
flugsicherung die senkung des jahres ein
kleines simulator wo fluglotsen die in
tauplitz tätig sind auf den vielen
österreich mit der kompletten neustart
einigen langen lebensweg hier die
möglichkeiten szenarien zu trainieren
die hoffentlich in der realität nicht
vorkommen wie beispielsweise
notverfahren das heißt große ist hier in
der lage sachen zu üben zu trainieren
notverfahren hier dann dementsprechend
analog einer checkliste abarbeiten muss
weiters gilt dieses haus monate auch zum
training militär fluglotsen
wenn neue plätze errichtet werden im
ausland beispielsweise wo man hier eben
sich auf diesen möglichen einsatz
vorbereiten kann
wir bewegen sind im zeitraum von etwa
drei bis vier wochen bis ein flugplatz
von unserem technischen support
verfügbar ist und somit können wir
gezielt fluglotsen auf einen auswärtigen
platz egal wo weltweit vorbereiten und
er kann bereits hier im simulator für
diesen ganz an diesen bringen
[Musik]